mais d'abord joe biden à l'heure d'un
premier bilan la défaite de son candidat
en virginie vient clore une séquence
orageuse pour le président américain
jordan klein
c'était il ya un an joe biden élu
président des états unis
le peuple de cette nation a parlé il
nous donne une victoire très nette
mais un an après ses deux victoires le
bilan semble mitigé et joe biden vient
d'en être témoin dans les urnes avec son
premier revers majeur ici dans l'état de
virginie
son candidat vient tout juste de
s'incliner face au républicain au poste
de gouverneur pourtant après son
investiture joe biden convainc il
reprend la main sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire relance la campagne de
vaccination et vente l'espoir d'un
retour à la normale
le 4 juillet il y a de fortes chances
que vous vos familles et vos amis
puissiez vous réunir dans votre jardin
ou dans votre quartier pour faire un
barbecue et célébrer la fête de
l'indépendance
l'un de ses premiers décrets à rebours
de l'administration trump et le retour
des etats-unis dans la cour de paris
seulement aujourd'hui tout semble bloqué
ces réformes pour un grand plan
d'investissements en matière climatique
sociale et pour de nouvelles
infrastructures sont au point mort
freiné par une majorité trop faible au
congrès les gens veulent que nous
fassions avancer les choses
c'est pourquoi je continue à pousser
très fortement pour que le parti
démocrate avance et vote mais projet de
loi
à l'international joe biden déçoit outre
la faire des sous marins avec la france
il décide après vingt ans de guerres de
quitter l'afghanistan laissant le champ
libre aux talibans et forçant ses alliés
à quitter le pays dans la précipitation
j'ai toujours promis au peuple américain
d'être franc avec vous la vérité est que
tout s'est déroulé bien plus rapidement
que nous l'avions prévu
un bilan qui pèsera sur les élections
dans un an de mi mandat cruciales elle
pourrait rebattre les cartes du pouvoir
by then and an après un premier bilan
avec nos experts patricia allemonière
bon soin
avenue grand reporter spécialiste de
politique internationale françois
durpaire bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université de cergy-pontoise
spécialiste des états unis vous publiez
les états unis pour les nuls c'est aux
éditions first jean-claude bonjour
bonsoir vous êtes avocat vice-président
de france amérique avec nos également en
visioconférence sonia dridi qui est
journaliste correspondante à washington
pour plusieurs médias et qui publie je
sais pas si on la voit déjà sonia
peut-être pas mais j'ai quand même citer
son livre joe biden le pari de
l'amérique en titre up aux éditions du
rocher voilà elle est présentée par son
livre frédéric séisme au soir thomas
bienvenue heureux de vous retrouver
éditorialiste politique france culture
un premier tour de table avec des
réponses assez rapide on aura le temps
de développer après mais si vous deviez
faire comme ça rapidement un premier
bilan un an après son élection et quoi
patricia allemonière d'agir et dans les
points positifs et bien son retour dans
le multilatéralisme
son retour dans l'accord de la coop 19
tout ça c'est des points positifs
ces efforts et financier pour relancer
l'économie américaine de faire des
grands travaux dans les points négatifs
l'homme avait dans toute sa campagne
c'était unir l'amérique réunir
l'amérique rassemblé échec pour
l'instant ça fonctionne pas françois
durpaire je vais pas faire les points
positifs et négatifs on aura le temps de
les voir mais j'ai recettes globales
je vais faire un pas de côté disons que
si joe biden regardé l'émission ou
l'équivalent cette émission aux etats
unis ils se diraient j'ai 50 ans de
bouteille à washington alors je suis pas
pour l'instant bien embarqué au niveau
de mes sondages mais je sais que la
présidence ce sont des cycles est donc
un bon président c'est un peu la
question tout historien c'est pas
un président qui n'a pas de point faible
ou qui n'a pas de bas sondages c'est un
président qui est capable de rebondir
certains ne rebondit jamais exemple
carter d'hôtes rebondissent exemple
reggane exemple obama exemple exemple
clinton on verra si yéro boly
effectivement c'est un peu trop tôt mais
là on est plutôt dans un cycle ah oui
d'accord c'est plutôt un mauvais cycle
oui très centré sur sa politique
domestique dès le départ déjà lors des
primaires démocrates les démocrates
étaient vraiment ancré sur leur
politique domestique il avait enfilé les
chaussures des républicains sur la lac
chine là dessus baden restent dans cette
ligne là sur l'interprofession chinoise
un petit peu cession
des façons c'est cela de ce point de vue
ça n'a pas changé parce que ça avait
déjà commencé avec obama et on oublie
très souvent que ben laden a été le vice
président de l'ac milan qui participent
il a participé à politique voulue par
par le président lente et sont montés
prédécesseur à l'international j'ai
envie de dire pas de surprise parce
qu'il a été relativement soft sur la
forme mais je pense qu'il fallait être
naïf pour imaginer que la politique
étrangère américaine aurait changé à 180
degrés et non lille reste on charge de
la défense des intérêts américains
intérêts du peuple américain mais aussi
de l'industrie américaine parce qu'il
faut oublier faut pas oublier qu'il ya
aussi l'industrie qui est très forte oui
les enjeux économiques y sont aussi très
fort et on n'en parle pas forcément dans
dans ce bilan vous parliez de la
popularité un coup d'oeil à cette
popularité c'est une source galope
évolution janvier et à 55 5 % d'opinions
positives en mai mais un pic à 63% on va
expliquer pourquoi on est dans la
période bons résultats économiques
campagne de vaccination qui qui
fonctionne aux états unis et puis là ce
fin octobre qui retombe à 44 7% sonia
dridi choix que vous êtes avec nous et
j'en profite pour vous saluer de visu
depuis washington
alors c'est peut-être très difficile de
répondre à cette question parce que
patricia disait que le l'objectif de
réconciliation n'est pas forcément
atteint on est face à une amérique qui
est souvent présenté comme fracturée
mais qu'est ce qui explique cette cote
de popularité en baisse qu'est ce qui
déçoit finalement les américains
alors je peux vous dire déjà
les démocrates par exemple à qui j'ai
parlé ces derniers temps notamment
j'étais en pire j la semaine dernière où
il ya eu donc cette élection qui était
vue comme un test pour
la le début de ce mandat de joe biden et
donc où les démocrates fillon ont
échoué un face à face au candidat
républicain et c'est vrai que j'ai
rencontré pas mal de démocrates déçus
qui beaucoup parlé de l'afghanistan par
exemple pour me dire que le retrait
avait
beaucoup supporté un soutenait ce
retrait mais que ça avait été très
chaotique d'autres trouvaient que les
réformes au congrès était bien trop
coûteuse donc ça c'était les démocrates
plutôt modéré d'autres au contraire que
qu'il n'allait pas qu'elle n'allait pas
assez loin donc c'est vrai que j'ai par
exemple en virginie la semaine dernière
j'ai eu du mal à rencontrer des
démocrates totalement satisfait de joe
biden je pense que c'est ce n'est pas
une surprise un c était moi je l'avais
écrit dans la conclusion de ma
biographie de joe biden donc avant avant
qu'il soit élu que si la lettre et s'il
allait être élu est bien l'une des
difficultés sa lettre de satisfaire les
progressistes et les démocrates les plus
modérés c'est vraiment ce qui se passe
en ce moment le début de mandat de joe
biden est minée par ses divisions entre
démocrates et modéré aujourd'hui par
exemple ni les démocrates qui disait au
new york times le hong a pas on ne
demande pas de dubaï d'être franklyn de
l'anneau svelte figure à laquelle il
s'est beaucoup pas comparer on lui
demande un retour à la normale et la fin
du chaos et donc il ya une division
entre ces démocrates qui ont élu joe
biden pour surtout se débarrasser de
donald trump qu'il ya un retour à la
normale et puis les démocrates qui
veulent aller plus vite notamment la
jeune génération qui veulent des
changements profonds dans la société et
que l'état providence ne soit plus un
gros mot j'en reprends la main de
secondes merci beaucoup sonia didry
andré dit on reviendra vers vous
évidemment tout à l'heure
françois durpaire c'est bon on peut se
demander pourquoi nous journalistes
français on s'intéresse à une élection
partielle en virginie ça peut sembler un
peu est ce qu'on n'est pas un peu dans
notre fascination éternelle pour
l'amérique mais pourquoi pourquoi c'est
une défaite importante c'est important
parce que il ya deux deux états qui ont
voté complètement donc on peut on peut
pas on peut parler de l'élection du
maire de new york louise est moins
intéressant évidemment là on a le
new-jersey et la virginie et en plus ils
se sont déplacés en nombre + 33 millions
c'est considérable
il ya quatre ans c'est beaucoup plus
qu'il ya quatre ans donc ça veut dire
qu'on n'est pas dans une élection
régionale française où on aurait du mal
à y trouver une participation nationale
forte et donc aller ce soir 1-1 déjà
c'est une première leçon c'est à dire
que la participation n'est pas
nécessairement favorable aux démocrates
là il ya des républicains qui se sont
mobilisés généralement 10 bonne
participation c'est les démocrates qui
votent les jeunes vont se dés benon là
ce sont des républicains qui se sont
déplacés et pourquoi c'est intéressant
pour deux choses d'ailleurs la victoire
la défaite des démocrates en virginie
est presque moins inquiétante que la
victoire de justesse dans le new-jersey
parce que n'oublions pas quand même que
il a gagné 2,16 points dans le
new-jersey il avait gagné 2,10 points en
virginie donc c'est évidemment on
compare le score de bayrou à la
présidentielle
donc on peut se dire un est-ce que déjà
la victoire de bayda n'était pas une
victoire en trompe l'oeil est-ce que ce
n'était pas une victoire en titre up et
puis deux
mais on voit que il ya un monde après
transavia que les républicains sont
capables de gagner après trente et et
glenn yongqing qui donc devient le
gouverneur de l'état de virginie il a
presque montré la voie à tous les
républicains qui veulent s'en sortir
après train il a fait quoi eh bien il
n'a pas cité train puis il n'a pas
appelé trump à son secours en revanche
il à flatter son électorat sur les mêmes
thématiques et en gros et ça va nous
parler en france il a fait le primat du
culturel sur le politique il a beaucoup
parlé il a ouvert des guerres
culturelles ce que faisait trappe mais
sans citer 30 et du côté démocrate mais
ça je vais pas beaucoup développé sonia
elle l'a dit on a vu les méfaits des
divisions au sein du parti démocrate
entre ces démocrates on le sait ouvriers
blancs d'un côté des modérés des
centristes et puis de l'autre ces
démocrates multiethnique féministe
jeunes écologistes c'est pas les mêmes
démocrates et ils ont réussi à se réunir
pour voter contre 30 mais lorsqu'il faut
se mobiliser pour city positivement on
voit que c'est un échec et là c'était
aussi un échec on le voit élection après
élection pour la gauche du parti
démocrate donc là effectivement on est
dans une période quand même mauvaise
mots le président j'ai refusé le bilan
mais je vais quand même vous dire un mot
sur le bilan il ya une manière de voir
est ce que c'est les événements qui
dirige le président ou est ce que c'est
le président qui dirige les événements
et bien en ce moment c'est les
événements qui dirige le président les
chaînes d'approvisionnement
le prix de l'essence l'inflation
le retour de la pandémie c'est pas du
fait tous deb hayden oui c'est les
événements ça fait un peu le lot des
chefs d'état
mais on est bien ici on a oublié que
derrière des élections de baden trump
avait fait plusieurs millions de voix
par rapport à sa première élection ça
veut bien dire qu'il a su donner une
dynamique chez les républicains et ça ça
ne peut pas s'être et tulle et en
l'espace d'une année et la deuxième pour
moi le deuxième le deuxième risque me
semble-t-il mais tout le monde l'a bien
compris c'est que nous sommes désormais
à quelques mois des élections de
mi-mandat donc ça vient c'est un mauvais
signal pour le président parce qu'il
faut quand il faudrait qu'en quelques
mois dit si le début du printemps qu'il
ait quelques trucs pour pouvoir
réveiller son électorat pouvoir redonner
confiance parce que je crains qu'il ne
soit sur un phénomène de glissement nous
ça va pour lui comme obama l'a connu
aussi ça va polluer complètement le
printemps je reprends l'un des arguments
que donner sonia dridi tout à leur
patrie rémunère sur l'afghanistan est ce
que est ce qu'il ya un avant et un après
retrait de l'afghanistan poupou revoilà
eva luise bilan de joe boyd comme elle l
évoquer cette question avec un
semble-t-il un goût militants ou
sympathisants je ne crois pas que les
questions internationales jeu tant que
ça dans les élections américaines et
dans le dans le sentiment est dans
l'adhésion des américains une politique
d'un président je crois que
effectivement ça n'a pas arrangé ses
affaires je dirais mais je crois que ce
qui est beaucoup plus important
aujourd'hui c'est le fait que les
démocrates de son n'ont plus peur de
trump ne sont plus mobilisés autour de
ce combat contre trump et donc ils sont
plus tôt face à la réalité de leur pays
et là dessus il y ait des divisions même
en leur sein il constate la division
partout il constate et très de joe biden
a abondonné en particulier aux
républicains des thèmes qui sont très
importants je crois aussi pour les
démocrates comme l'éducation ce sont des
thèmes qui l'a laissée complètement
tombé parce qu'il est pris par ces deux
plans qu'il veut à tout prix faire
passer parce qu'il pense qu'avec avec
ces mesures économiques et sociales
d'ailleurs avec ses 12 c'est ce double
plan qui en fait à verscio versus
sociale et climat et versus
infrastructures il sera re mobiliser son
électorat et il sera remporté ces
élections de mid-term je ne suis pas sûr
que s'il ne se concentre que sur ces
données là il puisse rassembler
l'électorat démocrate très attachés à
des phénomènes de société on vous
parlait de ses plans à la fois
d'infrastructures plan d aide sociale
encalminé devant les aléas terminer par
les mêmes démocrates ces deux démos cas
majorité seuls c'est extrêmement
intéressant parce que vu de france
parfois on a l'impression que le
président américain est surpuissant
première puissance du monde etc on
valide il est beaucoup plus contraints
par les que dans la vème république en
france c'est là c'est un homme
totalement et pas du tout puissant
président américain la main sur
l'international d'ailleurs la main sur
l'international comme un peu notre
président en cohabitation le domaine
réservé
l'impression qu'on a on dit souvent le
président des états unis l'homme le plus
puissant du monde mais par rapport à la
puissance américaine à l'extérieur mais
sur le plan interne le président des
états unis et est contraint ses
négociations avec le congrès en
permanence on n'imagine pas une seconde
donnant mandat pour un français donnant
mandat un président est un président
dans l'impossibilité de gagner certains
parlementaires sa majorité
c'est inconcevable dans notre cas c'est
exotique this effectivement c'est à ce
ce pouvoir que mais c'était vrai nom
pendant le banc de mandat de barack
obama quant à auchan biographie idée il
décrit sa bonne foi alors c'est vrai que
on se dit joe biden on sait pas si on
doit le placer du côté des présidents
qui ont beaucoup d'humilité il a quand
même dit je serai un président de
transition kamala harris
ou un président extrêmement arrogant
parce que finalement son modèle
politique c'est pas un modèle d'un
président discret et c'est c'est
franklin delano roosevelt et juste après
lyndon johnson donc ce sont des
présidents qui ont voulu marquer de leur
empreinte l'histoire du pays il a dans
le bureau ovale un portrait de dylan au
roosevelt et il a quand même dit que ces
réformes et en particulier le fameux sa
fameuse réforme de reconstruire en mieux
eh bien c'était du roosevelt plus
johnson déjà l'historien il fait juste
un calcul le new deal c'était 40 % du
pib 1929 40% du pib 1929 investi dans le
new deal sont son bulbe l'outback better
l'ascenson de son plan s'il passe 1750
milliards de dollars plus la corde
infrastructures les 500 milliards de
dollars plus je vous rajoute pour
quelqu'un qui a aucun pouvoir et il est
capable quand même de dépenser de vos
courses le secours qu'ovide 19 c'était
1900 milliards de dollars on additionne
tout ça ça fait 10 9% du pib de 2019 on
est bien en-deça du new deal enfin c'est
quand même pas mal
c'est un retour de l'état fédéral mais
vous avez tout à fait raison le fameux
djoman chine qui l'a se sent plus depuis
cette défaite là et et christine cinéma
qui ont tous les deux le pouvoir de
blocage bien et vous aussi avoir ce
pouvoir de comment va dépenser 1 parce
que effectivement si on va au bout c'est
pour ça que c'est le dur de faire cette
émission avant de savoir si on va au
bout complètement de ce projet là parce
que si on va au bout de la garde
d'enfant ce qu'il veut faire c'est deux
choses les emplois verts et puis c'est
le fait de pouvoir faire garder son
enfant quand on est un parent salariés
et ça c'est une révolution dans
l'histoire du pays s'il va ou donc les
ambitions une ambiance une ambition et
les royals elle est pas totalement
enterrée considérable s'il va au bout de
ça là on va refaire une émission en
quinze jours en disant ouais désolé
monsieur monsieur monsieur vous faites
voilà désolé monsieur buydens vous êtes
un très grand président s'il va pas au
bout de sa belle a effectivement ça sera
alors je veux redonner à paris juste
après je voudrais écouter sonia dridi là
dessus parce que effectivement c'est ces
réformes qui sont malgré tout ambitieuse
même si en comparaison de celle de
franklin d roosevelt c'est peut-être un
peu en dessous mais malgré tout c'est
très ambitieux quand on a ces sommes
additionnées elles ne sont pas enterrés
il ya une capacité de joba yens
d'ailleurs à peine de retour de dudu du
g20 et s'est il s'est plongé dans dans
ces enjeux oui tout à fait c'est sa
priorité hier il a dit aux élus avant
son il faut avancer et joe biden est
extrêmement frustré de voir ce ces
réformes qui ne passe pas au congrès
notamment parce que vous l'avez dit il y
a deux démocrates de deux sénateurs
démocrates kiki mais qui bloquent le
passage de céret et d'ailleurs pour joe
biden s'est vraiment ce qu'ils devaient
définir très rapidement son mandat c'est
une priorité et puis 2 du code de
l'autre côté bien les centres il y aller
et plus progressif qui sont très déçus
que comme l'a dit françois durpaire ce
plan était réduit de moitié pour
l'instant parce que il y à des besoins
très importants aux états unis par
exemple pour parler de l'éducation je
pense pas que joe biden dont la femme
d'ailleurs la première dame est
enseignante mettre complètement de côté
l'éducation parce que dans ce plan les
mesures sociales il y a notamment le
plus grand accès aux community college
dont des universités
gratuite ou en tout cas moins chers que
les grandes universités privées il y à
la crèche
la crèche gratuites et la maternelle
gratuite il faut savoir qu'aux états
unis ça coûte très cher d'avoir des
enfants dans les grandes villes la
crèche ou la maternelle ça peut coûter
1000 à 2000 dollars par mois donc il ya
vraiment la volonté de schaub hayden et
je pense que ça c'est pas seulement pour
faire plaisir à l'oeil gauche il a
vraiment envie de changer en profondeur
la société américaine avec ces mesures
sociales et c'est parce que il à ce
programme très ambitieux que cinq ans
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de démocrates
modérés qui ont peur finalement de ne
pas être élu si les électeurs trouve que
justement c'est ces réformes vont sont
trop coûteux c'est ce que m'ont dit
certains démocrates modérés d'ailleurs
en virginie mais c'est en effet la
priorité de joe biden parce que il a
aussi il sait aussi pendant sa campagne
comparer justement à franklin delano
roosevelt en disant qu'il voulait ce
retour de l'état providence donc c'est
sa priorité et en effet les il pourrait
y avoir un vote déjà dès ce soir est en
tout cas dans les prochaines semaines
les premiers prochains mois on va
vraiment voir si si c'est ces réformes
peuvent enfin passé et c'est je pense
qu'il est aussi une frustration du côté
des électeurs démocrates parce que il
déjà il ya la fatigue posco vide en tout
cas de deux toiles à de peu ce qui est
en train de sceller les choses
n'avancent pas autant que certains
aimeraient et puis de voir que
finalement il ya des votes qui sont
annulés ces réformes qui passent pas les
électeurs démocrates en dehors de
washington sont complètement perdu et
sont là c'est finalement et ils ont
beaucoup sont déçus et c'est aussi pour
ça que pie ii ne perd en popularité
parce qu'ils espéraient que ça aille
plus vite j'aimerais qu'on reparle un
peu de donald trump qui a lancé son
réseau social mais qui s'appelle tous
c'est quand même gonflé de la peur d'eux
le sens de la pop de ce mec a quand même
beaucoup menti pendant son son mandat on
va dire ça comme ça jean claude
bourgeois à quel point il pèse donald
trump sur le calendrier ou l'actualité
politique américaine est ce qu'il est
encore là est-ce que c'est ces
interventions sont sont suivis commentée
par là par la presse il ya des choses je
pense que tout d'abord lui-même ne
définit pas son projet de manière claire
il dit qu'il reviendra sous quelle forme
on ne sait toujours pas les contacts
qu'on a sur le terrain parce que
certains certains amis suivent cesser
ces déclarations le suivent un peu sur
ces certains certaines réunions qu'il
organise avec ses amis il n'est pas très
bien arrêtées sur la suite une chose qui
est certaine c'est qu'il veut il s'est
pris au jeu et donc il veut continuer à
peser il sent que le parti républicain a
besoin ou voudraient avoir un leader il
se dit pourquoi pas moi dans sa décision
n'est pas prise ce qui sera important
c'est probablement un certain nombre
d'affaires qui sont encore qui traînent
autour ce que ça lui coûtera est ce
qu'il aura les moyens et ce qui sera en
état y compris physiquement d'aller
lever de l'argent même chose est
certaine c'est qu'il a pris un peu de
goût ou au pouvoir et il n'a pas dit son
dernier mot alors est-ce que les
américains pourraient revoter parce que
c'est ça le vrai sujet alors général
quand on a perdu on a perdu aux états
unis on ne renie pas la chose il faut
pas avoir été candidate trois fois
encore que nixon et était revenu il
avait emporté mais de donald trump se
tâte encore je pense qu'il pèse encore
il pèse il ya une cette influence
culturelle ou là la doctrine il parle
encore au sens l'amérique profonde il
veut encore se être le chant de
l'amérique profonde cette amérique
anciennes là dessus il a encore une
petite marge de manoeuvre parce qu'il
fait peur par exemple au cadre
républicain ce qu'ils auront besoin de
lui pour l'élection est libre
non ce qui fait pas peur et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il ne fait pas
peur même sa popularité a même augmenté
dans une vraie de ceux qui qui sont qui
font partie de son électorat
traditionnel mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir l'élection de galles jean
king parce que lui effectivement dans
toute sa campagne comme vous l'avez l'un
d'eux vous l'a dit il a repris les
thèmes de trope mais il ne l'a jamais
suscité donc ça dessine
pour les républicains et aujourd'hui
parmi ces voix on pense à ivanka et je
pense que le père donald ont cassé la
fidh
donc tout le déjà il ya cette rumeur est
géré en demandera votre correspondante
qui qui qui est là aux états unis ou
dans le camp dans le camp républicain on
parle d'ivanka et je pense qu'elle n'est
pas quelle
cause d'une marque et il faut la garder
tout en oubliant l'homme en quelques
mots les américains sonia dridi adore
les sagas adore les dynasties ça c'est
dans l'isoloir investir et américaines
oui tout à fait alors ses c'est un peu
difficile de prévoir ce qui se passera
dans quelques années mais c'est vrai que
donald trump certains de ses conseillers
proches le disent à une intention
sérieuse maintenant de se présenter à la
prochaine élection présence est alors
beaucoup de choses peuvent changer d'ici
là mais c'est vrai que certains
conseillers ont confié par exemple au
washington post que quand donald trump a
vu par exemple la débâcle autour de
l'afghanistan et bien ça lui a donné
encore plus de motivation
pour pour penser à un straw a présenté
en paix alors on a des petits problèmes
de liaison donc on va vous redonner la
parole aux instants mais tiens j'en
profite j'en profite pour redonner la
citation de donald trump et qui réagit
justement pour autre américain et voilà
ce qu'il dit sur joe biden le dirigeant
de notre pays et passer pour un idiot
nous avons du mal à nous remettre de
l'emba que cette incompétence à a causé
et c'est daté du 11 septembre
surprenante de
la fait dire par ailleurs on est
d'accord donaldson qui ceux qui se
moquaient de du slip ibai donne pendant
la campagne électorale est ce que
françois durpaire le président actuel
joe biden a pu effacer un peu cette
cette image ou pas oui alors il a effacé
en partie mais mais pas pour pas porte
donné le train c'est à dire que
quand on regarde le style de présidence
de bynum puisque l'objet c'est aussi de
faire le bilan de deux de ses de ce
début de mandat c'est un style classique
de présidence c'est à dire que si vous
prenez part en plus fâché coeur du
washington post qui continuent à
fonctionner il s'est pas arrêtée et déjà
qu'on l'accuse d'être démocrate s'il
s'était arrêtée après 32 ans
fils et les mensonges de bail donne il
avait il avait pointé 30000 mensonges de
donald trump au cours de son mandat en
ce jour de maiden il y en avait 511
c'est pas des mensonges
c'est sa vraie et demi ça fait des 2000
vérité où ça peut être simplement des
déserts vous allez pas soirée de vérité
alternative à méfier c'est pas mon genre
mais qu'est-ce qui le remarque ce fac
shaker d'abord un qu'abidal ne répète
pas les allégations mensongères
tiens qu'on lui dise ça c'est faux il ne
corrige pas tandis que de notre âme dit
si si je vous assure que si et il répété
c'est vous qui avez tort c'est vos
chiffres qui sont faux deuxième chose
que c'est le fruit d'une présidence je
lisais plus classique avec des textes
qui sont préparés avec un fruit
collectif intellectuelle autour de ce
qu'il dit évidemment beaucoup moins
d'improvisation face aux journalistes
beaucoup moins d'utilisation de twitter
il a utilisé par exemple 65 % de choix -
twitter au cours de ses 100 premiers
jours que 2 1 30 et puis aussi que sa
parole entre guillemets et d'or c'est à
dire qu'il s'exprime moins on donnera
moins de bêtises tu sais c'est quand
même beaucoup moins cette intervention
contre 22 à donald trump au cours de la
même période deux conférences de presse
alors qu'il en avait fait 9 donald trump
au cours de ses 100 premiers jours mais
ce qui est tout à fait
que dans un temps d'accélération
médiatique qui si c'est intéressant
oridion la parole c'était un peu la
stratégie ce sont des revenus très vite
un dernier petit mot effectivement c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est que on est
à l'heure des réseaux sociaux et
qu'effectivement donald trump il avait
un peu cassé le job lui il était
complètement en phase avec ce temps
d'accélération et comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure on a quand même une
situation inédite dans l'histoire
contemporaine américaine d'un président
ex président qui intervient massivement
dans la politique nationale ça ça
n'existe pas aux états unis ça n'existe
pas dans la période contemporaine
donald trump intervient massivement
lourd sur le plan de la forme sur le
plan du fond les deux axes déclinés
chaos c'est la catastrophe et puis
toujours le même thème identitaire la
frontière l'émigration qui est toujours
toujours la même chose évidemment la
seule la bonne nouvelle pour les
républicains qui ne sont pas trompés
c'est qu'évidemment comme le disait jean
claude l'idée de marque trump c'est à
dire qu'il ya des marques républicaine
post re-up lyon qu'il en est
l'illustration le moteur de la
mobilisation s'est donné un train pour
le voit on parle de trump construire ils
se sont mobilisés encore en virginie
mais la marque elle n'était pas trompé
elle était
en relation franco la communité huit ans
vice-président et qui sait que le peuple
américain attend sur les résultats
concrets de sa politique domestique et
il en a gardé comme expérience qui avait
vécu obama les gens ne voyaient pas
venir ici c'est que c'est l'agrégé
connaît
exactement
cc
il est dit il fait plein de choses quand
même lyon roanne endormi en train de
rejouer en joue oui j'aime pas rappeler
son aide va fêter ses 70 devant le 20
novembre je peux pas le faire parce que
parce qu'on a un débat sur le grand âge
juste après et je compte change le
regard sur sur les seniors bref elle
file très contradictoires mais on assume
nos contradictions ici aussi acte i
oui j'espère bien 79 en voyant alors la
réconciliation entre la france et les
états unis après la crise des sous
marins australiens on va ouvrir ce thème
là même si ça pour le coup ça doit pas
du tout intéressé les électeurs de joe
biden ça doit pas être centrales aux
états unis et pour commencer je lui ai
donné la parole à steve jourdain qui va
nous rejoindre bonsoir steve vous êtes
partis à la rencontre des sénateurs qui
notamment sont férus de politique dans
la zone al qui siège à la commission des
affaires étrangères pour ben alors posé
la même question à un bilan est un vilan
on voit là bas ils sont plutôt d'accord
avec vos invités ans thomas c'est un
bilan en demi-teinte clairement pour joe
biden petit résumé peut-être du
sentiment qui domine ici au sénat avec
andré gattolin le vice président de la
commission des affaires étrangères
sénateurs r&d pays la république en
marche écoutez le il ya eu un grand
espoir des européens y compris des
français pas rêvé par rapport à
l'arrivée de joe biden moi à l'époque
j'avais dit méfiant nous parce que la
tendance j'irai aux états unis à se
replier sur eux mêmes n'est pas nouvelle
elle a d'obama elle était renforcée par
trump et le
l'administration train l'administration
maiden aujourd'hui et et à des positions
extrêmement dur extrêmement forte
évidemment on pense à eaunes haussier
des sous marins australiens ce que nous
avons fait était maladroit voilà ce qu'a
déclaré joe biden à rome lors de sa
rencontre avec emmanuel macron la
semaine dernière cette affaire des
sous-marins elle a clairement jeté un
froid entre les deux pays ici au sénat
thomas il était un temps question de
mettre sur pied une commission d'enquêté
pour faire toute la lumière sur les
dessous du contrat du siècle qui a donc
été chipé par les américains la gauche
ici souhaité cette commission denquête
la droite et le centre étaient beaucoup
moins chaud ici au sénat la majorité
elle est de droite et du centre et du
coup il n'y aura pas de commission
denquête au sénat on réécoute andré
gattolin là dessus ce n'était pas une
bonne idée qui a pas matière à
commission denquête surtout on va pas
comme eux on va pas convoqué le premier
ministre d'australie où le président des
états unis pour leur demander les semis
sous serment de s'expliquer devant le
parlement français c'est un coup
politique joué par l'opposition et par
le parti socialiste pour des royaux
existe on est très bien les accords je
rappelle ont été conclus à l'époque où
quand même c'est elle qui dirige l des
affaires les prochains défis pour les
relations franco américaines a comme 26
à glasgow qui s'est ouverte lundi thomas
joe biden promet des accords ambitions
ça tombe très bien emmanuel marc on
demande les accords ambitieux ou
peut-être se retrouver sur ce sur ce
thème là est-ce que patricia dierick la
la crise les sous-marins elle et elle
est derrière nous derrière ou derrière
eux puisque c'était c'était aussi des
images de réconciliation entre entre
deux présidents alors moi j'ai avec la
réconciliation elle était très a minima
quand on a beau regarder la gestuelle on
avait un empressement des manuels macron
qui le prenaient joe biden par le dos
qui voulait toucher qui voit la très
sympathique on voyait joe joe biden qui
filait au loin et qui s'éloigne à une
très belle image là dessus oui aussi
cette autre image cette odeur dans la
photo où joe biden
j'apporte un peu le genou croissance
interne elle dans votre sens parce que
la façon dont il a dit en gros au web on
s'est trompé en a failli dans ce gentil
oui c'était comme un père qui dit à son
petit temps de fond son petit garçon bon
coup tu vas pas nous faire toute une
histoire je me suis trompé c'est pas
grave on continue ensemble donc moi j'ai
trouvé que c'était
vraiment à minimes et et j'ai trouvé que
la france finalement bon bien ok ce
qu'on espère dans cette histoire parce
que finalement on s'est aussi incliné il
faut le dire est qu est-ce qu on espère
on espère avoir en échange de deux sets
de ce retour vers pape a en quelque
sorte papa byden qu'est ce qu'on espère
avoir et bien la défense européenne on
espère que joe biden va faire pression
sur ces hamdi anglais pour leur dire
passé à bergues et sur ses amis
allemands puisque c'est avec l' axe
essentiel de joe biden maintenant c'est
le retour à l'ancien axe c'est
l'amérique et l'allemagne donc il va
faire pression sur ses amis allemands
qui sont pas très empressés de en ce qui
concerne la défense européenne pour
faire accepter cette défense européenne
quant au sahel ce qu'on y gagne trois
hélicoptères de plus dans le ciel c'est
pas grand chose ils étaient là avant
ceux qui nous ont permis de d'éliminer
tous les djihadistes grâce à leur
service des coudes donc je pense pas
qu'ils peuvent faire beaucoup beaucoup
plus c'est eux qui approvisionne tous
nos avions dans le ciel ils sont là on
là où on les attend c'est sur la défense
européenne et on les attend justement ce
que nous avons fait était maladroit
steve journal le rappelait cette
citation de jubail on va écouter un peu
plus longuement ce que ce que dit le
chic est le cas résidents américains on
l'écouté et puis il a bel
et bien laissez-moi affirmer quelque
chose d'évident nous n'avons pas
d'alliés plus anciens plus loyal ou plus
honnête que la france
je pense que ce qui s'est passé c'est
que pour utiliser une expression
anglaise ce que nous avons fait était
maladroit n'a pas été fait avec beaucoup
de grâce j'avais l'impression que
certaines choses s'étaient produites
alors que ce n'était pas le cas mais je
veux que ce soit clair la france est un
partenaire extrêmement extrêmement
précieux extrêmement et une puissance en
soit
la france est une puissance en soit jean
claude beauchaud à ce que le simple fait
de te voir le rappeler n'est pas
révélateur finalement ben oui vous savez
on d'hab on a été très content beaucoup
ont dit enfin 30 des parties voici byden
on a oublié qu effectivement le
président des états unis défendrait les
intérêts américaine notamment la
puissance américaine sa puissance
économique on voit bien le président
baden où dit il ya une maladresse mais
je rappelle que la maladresse nous a
coûté 50 milliards ça c'est une chose
dont il m'adresse à 50 milliards ça fait
un peu cher et puis dit je croyais donc
on est un peu dans l'approximation l'air
de dire ce sont mes collaborateurs dont
qu'il ment pas il dit ce sont mes
collaborateurs je n'étais pas très
informé et donc je prends conscience et
puis on va réfléchir on va regarder de
l'avant et guerre ou autre chose aussi
il faut pas oublier que nous avons dans
la zone nous avons un intérêt nous
allons avoir des des élections nouvelle
calédonie lie à la présence française
donc tout ça était important pour nous
je pense que c'est une mauvaise façon
qu'on nous a fait en tout cas les
américains les australiens des
britanniques c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose d'assez exaspérant cela
étant dit est ce que le président
français avait tellement le choix en
disant bon ben c'est dont ap et puis
regardons de l'avant goût regardons de
l'avant il n'avait pas tellement le
choix parce qu'une que marge de
manoeuvre est faible il reste c'est
qu'effectivement il faudra que mâcon
soit très fonctionnel pouvoir les sortir
du commandement intégré certaines
voulaient
et c'est vrai aussi vous disiez à minima
c'est vrai que joe biden aurait pu faire
le choix de passer par paris avant
d'arriver à rome c'était pas très
compliqué non
la force one le
président français a attendu une heure
et demie le prix d'amérique ce qui là
aussi est évident mais effectivement est
ce que la france est encore une
puissance qui comptent les états unis je
pense qu'il faut dire clairement le
regard américain est essentiellement
tournée vers l'asie et le pacifique et
vers la chine cela dit dans les
décisions qui ont été prises par paris
au moment de cette grande fratrie c'est
à dire le rappel des ambassadeurs est ce
que finalement ça a servi à quelque
chose françois durpaire ou est-ce que
c'était une forme de démonstration qui
finalement n'aboutit pas à des
phénomènes il ya des réponses très
concrètes de la part de washington déjà
le rappel de l'ambassadeur c'est un acte
diplomatique fort symbolique s'est
jamais produit entre les deux pays on
l'a on l'avait fait avec l'italie on
l'avait fait avec la turquie on n'a
jamais fait avec les états unis et on
vient de faire avec la grande bretagne
ont fait la loi montagne bottes mais on
se rappelle que pour la faire des sous
marins on n'a pas rappelé l'ambassadeur
de londres s'est tapé sur les états unis
s'en taper sur sur le royaume uni ce qui
est quand même c'est vrai important
c'est de sortir un peu du syndrome de
l'allier facile on finit par oublier et
qu'on finit par piétiner thales que
l'allié facile c'est à dire que je suis
toujours là
on est la fayette à et des américains
mais américains ont aidé la france et
ses alliés facile qui finira toujours
par se rallier à vous on peut regarder
bien sûr et on fait pas attention est-ce
qu'il est sorti emmanuel macron de ce
syndrome de l'allier facile à un émoi
sur ça va que ce mea culpa alors c'est
vrai que les hommes politiques et femmes
politiques n'aiment pas faire de mea
culpa les 10 hommes et femmes pas sûr
parce qu angela merkel a fait
la fée sur le confinement en face
d'ailleurs vous rappeler les articles
certains ont dit voyez les femmes
politiques agissent différemment des
hommes politiques on va pas revenir là
dessus à la
scène mais aussi les américains savent
présenter des excuses en clair
la cia la plage au bal de nuit jo
bagnols ne représente jamais 18 nous
verrons prenez sa vie politique hors
produits quand même la mère de toutes
les erreurs de bayonne sur l'afghanistan
ce qu'il a il a fait une série d'erreurs
incroyable sur l'afghanistan des erreurs
de communication
considérable en disant vous ne verrez
jamais les mêmes images qu à saigon jeu
le traitement jean-claude le sait le
traitement des visas tout a été fait en
dépit du bon sens et joe biden n'a
jamais choisi mea culpa là il fait une
sorte de mea culpa sur la forme parce
que inélégant ça veut pas dire qu'il
regrette de l'avoir fait et puis on se
dédouanant sur les australiens mais
beaucoup plus globalement il ya quand
même une un problème très fort de sa
politique étrangère à à joe biden kelly
sa doctrine obama on le sait c'était le
smart power
autres up america first on le résume
d'un mot si on est professeur on a des
étudiants on explique obama en cinq
minutes trump on peut le faire aussi by
donne c'est quoi sa stratégie un camion
aux banques américaines ce bac et on se
retire de tout et on se retire
d'afghanistan les images ne coïncide pas
avec le slogan fareed zakaria qui a des
penseurs de la politique étrangère vous
savez ce monde post américain disait à
washington post il normalise la
politique étrangère de donald trump je
dis pas que c'est vrai que je dis qu'on
peut le dire tellement c'est confus or
c'est son cv il a présidé cette
commission raffarin donc c'est
absolument fondamental et pour lui
effectivement il est vers la chine là on
sait tous l'importance et taiwan c'est
la pression que la chine fait à taiwan
mais il a besoin d'europe il a besoin de
l'europe patricia je crois que il a
besoin de l'europe mais l'europe en tout
cas une certaine partie l'europe n'a
aucune envie d'aller faire la guerre en
mer de chine
de la chine et ça c'est le président
macron l'a dit très clairement la france
n'est pas intéressé par cette histoire
même si effectivement nous avons des
territoires dans le dallas dans la zone
pacifique mais l'histoire de la chine
c'est l'histoire de l'amérique face à la
chine pour l'instant merci beaucoup
merci à tous merci sonia dridi j'appelle
le titre de votre livre joe biden le
pari de l'amérique en titre umps et est
publié aux éditions du rocher françois
durpaire les états unis pour les nuls
c'est chez first merci à tous on passe